♪ (music) ♪
Hi there, everyone.
I'm excited to introduce a new project
that we've been working on
that takes a new project
to improve usability of TensorFlow.
And we care so much about usability here
that we're going all the way back
to first principles
of the computation we're performing.
But first, why usability?
I felt that everyone here agrees
that productivity
in machine learning is critical,
because it leads to a faster pace
of innovation and progress in our field.
Of course, we just want to build
beautiful things for TensorFlow users,
so that's a big piece of it as well.
But if you look
at machine learning frameworks
there's two major approaches.
The most familiar
are the graph building approaches
where you explicitly define a graph
and then execute it
to run your computation.
This is great for performance,
but isn't always the best for usability.
In contrast, the define-by-run approaches
like eager execution
aren't always the best for performance,
but allow you to use language control flow
and other things that make them
a lot easier to use.
The interesting thing
about both approaches
is that they're really
about allowing Python to understand
the difference between
the Tensor computation in your code
and all the other non-Tensor stuff,
like command line option processing
and visualization,
and the other things you do.
So, I think it's interesting
to look at how these actually work.
In the case of eager execution,
for example, you write your model
and Python starts out by parsing it,
and then it feeds every statement
at a time to the interpreter.
And if it's a Tensor operation,
it fires up TensorFlow and hands it off,
and TensorFlow takes care
of your Tensor operations.
Otherwise, the Python interpreter runs it.
The key thing about eager execution
and graph building
is that they're designed
within the constraints
of what you can do as a Python library.
Now, if you crack open the compiler
and look at it from what could we do
with the compiler and language involved,
there is a whole other set of approaches
that can be applied to solving
this particular problem
and that's what we're doing.
The cool thing about a compiler
is that after you parse your code,
the compiler can see the entire program
and all the Tensor ops in it.
And so what we're doing
is we'll add a new stage to the compiler
that automatically takes
these Tensor operations
out of your program,
builds a standard
TensorFlow graph for you,
and then hands it to TensorFlow.
Since it's a standard TensorFlow graph,
you get full access to all things
that TensorFlow can do,
including all the devices.
Now, we think that this approach
is a really great combination,
because you get all the power
and flexibility of TensorFlow,
but you also get the usability
of your execution as well.
But there's a catch.
There's always a catch, right?
The catch here is that
we can't do this with Python.
At least, not with
the reliability we expect,
because it doesn't support
the kind of compiler analysis we need.
And what do we mean by that?
The compiler has to be able
to reason about values
as they flow through your program.
It has to reason about control flow
and function calls.
It has to reason about variable aliasing
and other things like that.
If we can't directly use Python,
then, as users, of course,
we care a lot about all the nice things
we've come to love about Python,
including the ability to use
all the standard Python APIs.
So, I know what you're thinking.
"Does this mean that we're talking
about doing a new language?"
That's definitely an approach to solve
the technical requirements we want,
and if we do new language,
we can obviously build
all the nice things we want into it.
But this comes at a cost
because it turns out
that we'd be foregoing
the benefits of having a community.
That includes things like tools
and libraries, but also things like books,
which some people still use.
And even more significantly,
this would take years of time to get right
and machine learning just moves too fast.
No, we think it's better
to use an existing language.
But here we have to be careful,
because to do this right,
we have to make significant improvements
to the compiler and the language
and we need to be able
to do this in a reasonable amount of time.
So, of course, this brings us
to the Swift programming language.
Now, I assume that most of you
are not very familiar with Swift,
so here's a quick introduction.
Swift is designed
with a lightweight syntax
and it's really geared toward
being easy to use and learn.
Swift draws together best practices
from lots of different places,
including things
like functional programming and generics.
Swift builds on LVM, which means,
of course, that it has an interpreter
and it has scripting capabilities as well.
Swift is great in notebook environments,
and these are really awesome
when you're interactively
developing in real time.
Swift is also open source.
It's portable to lots of platforms
and has a big community of people.
The number one thing
that's most important to us
is it has a fully open design environment,
called "Swift Evolution,"
which allows us to propose
first-class machine learning
language and compiler features
directly for integration into Swift.
If you bring all of this together
that we've been talking about here,
I'm happy to introduce
Swift for TensorFlow.
Swift for TensorFlow gives you
the full performance of graphs,
you can use native language control flow,
has built-in support
for automatic differentiation,
it can detect errors in your code
without even running it,
and it has full access to Python APIs.
Instead of telling you about it,
here is Richard Wei to show it to you now.
Thank you, Chris.
(applause)
I'm thrilled to show you
Swift for TensorFlow.
Swift is a high-performance,
modern programming language.
And today, for the very first time,
Swift has a full-power
TensorFlow built right in.
I'm going to walk through
three major styles of programming:
scripting, interpreting, and notebooks.
So, first let me show you
the Swift interpreter.
This is a Swift interpreter.
When I type some code, Swift evaluates it
and prints the result, just like Python.
Now, let's import TensorFlow.
(keyboard clacking)
I can create a Tensor from some scalers.
I can do any TensorFlow operation directly
and see the result,
just like I would with eager execution.
For example, a + a,
or [ACE] matrix product with itself.
Of course, loops just work.
I can print the result [of it].
Interpreter is a lot of fun to work with,
but I like using TensorFlow
in a more interactive environment,
just like Jupyter Notebook,
so let's see how they work.
This is a Swift notebook.
It shows all the results on the right.
So, here's a more interesting code:
Fun with Functions.
So, here I have
a sigmoid function inside a loop.
Now, as I click on this button,
it shows a trace of all values
produced by this function over time.
Now, as a machine learning developer,
I often like to differentiate functions.
Now, when I type in--
Well, since we were able to improve
the programming language,
we built first-class
automatic differentiation
right into Swift.
Now, when I type in "gradient effects,"
it shows the gradient.
Swift computes the gradient automatically
and gives me the result.
So, here's the gradient sigmoid.
Now, let's look at some Python code.
Let's think about Python.
Well, as a machine learning developer,
I've been using Python a lot
and I know there are
many great Python libraries.
Just today, my colleague, Dan,
sent me a data set in pickle format.
I can directly use Python APIs to load it.
All I have to do
is to type in "import Python,"
and Swift uses a Python API,
pickle, to be specific, to load the data.
Here you can see the data
right in the Swift notebook.
So, here's the Swift notebook.
Now, some people
like to run training script
directly in command line.
So, let me show you how to train
a simple model in command line.
So, here is a simple MNIST model.
In this model, I'm using TensorFlow's
data set API to load training data.
As I scroll down, I have the forward pass,
backward pass, gradient descent,
all defined in the training loop.
Now, I usually like to work on the go,
so this code has been working
on a CPU on my laptop.
But when I want to get
more performance, what do I do?
Well, why don't I just enable Cloud TPU?
So, all I have to do is add one line
to enable TPU execution.
When I save this file, open a terminal
to run this training script,
it's initializing TPU
and the Swift compiler
automatically partitions this program
into a normal subprogram
and a TensorFlow graph.
And TensorFlow is sending this graph
to the TensorFlow XLA compiler
for TPU execution.
Now, it's running and we're waiting
for the TPU to give the result.
Look, loss is going down!
All right!
Why don't we simply open TensorBoard
and see the training curve.
Now I can see the entire
training history in TensorBoard.
So, this is looking great.
Now, this is Swift for TensorFlow.
It's an interactive programming experience
with supercomputing performance
at your fingertips.
Back to you, Chris.
(Chris) Thanks, Richard.
(applause)
All right, to recap quickly,
Richard showed you
that Swift has an interpreter
and it works just like you'd expect.
Now, I know that it's super frustrating
to be working on a program,
and two hours into a training run
you get a shape error or a type mismatch.
Swift is designed to catch errors early,
and we've started building in support
for catching TensorFlow-specific mistakes
right into TensorFlow.
We showed that you can directly use
arbitrary Python APIs
and other dynamic languages
directly from Swift,
which gives you full access
to the data science ecosystem
and any other Python APIs
that you just love to use.
Swift is also generating
standard TensorFlow graphs,
including control flow,
which give you the full performance
of the session API.
Of course, graphs are also awesome
because they give you access
to everything that TensorFlow can do,
including devices spanning the range
from the tiniest Raspberry Pi
all the way up to a TPU supercomputer.
Now, you may be wondering
when do you get this, what does this mean?
This is still an early-stage project,
but I'm happy to say
that we're looking forward
to our open source release next month.
And not only are we releasing the code,
we're releasing technical white papers
and documents that explain how it works.
And we're also moving
our design discussions
out into the public onto Google Groups,
so that everybody
who wants to can participate.
Now, we're not done yet.
So, we have basic support
for automatic differentiation
built right into the compiler
on the language.
But we're also really interested
in extending it to support exotic cases,
like recursion, and even differentiating
custom data structures.
Compatibility issues
are also super frustrating,
particularly if you accidentally
use an op or a dtype
that's not supported by your device.
Swift has great support for detecting
availability issues like this,
and we're looking forward to wiring this
right into support TensorFlow.
We're also interested in high-level APIs,
but with this, we want to be
a little bit cautious.
We have some prototypes now,
but we'd really like to work
with the community
and evaluate and iterate
and design multiple different approaches
and actually experiment with these,
and then settle on the best one
based on real-world experience.
This has been a super quick tour
of Swift for TensorFlow.
Swift for TensorFlow combines
the power and flexibility of TensorFlow
with a whole new standard for usability.
We think it will take your productivity
and shoot it to the roof.
Swift for TensorFlow
is also an early-stage project
and so we'd really love
for you to get interested
and help us to build this future.
Thank you.
(applause)
♪ (music) ♪